think of this green thing as a
stationary point from this point say
you're running towards the right at the
speed of 10 km/h this point is
stationary and you are running towards
the right at some speed how far from
this point will you be after one hour
I'm asking your simple question
this point is stationary and you are
running towards the right at a speed of
10 km/h where will you be after one hour
you will be somewhere here 10 kilometers
away from the starting point when it
comes to speed this is the concept we
are used to we relate our position to a
stationary point here every hour we will
keep moving 10 kilometers further away
from this point and that's why we say
that the speed is 10 kilometers per hour
relative to this stationary object but
let's think of another situation take
the stationary point from this point a
travels at the speed of 5 km/h to the
right and B travels in the same
direction at the speed of 10 km/h both
leave the starting point at the same
time now I ask you another question what
is the speed of B relative to a you are
not asked for the speed of B relative to
the stationary point you are asked for
the speed of B relative to a let's zoom
out to make some space here to know the
relative speed let's look at their
positions after one hour don't forget
they leave at the same time so a will be
somewhere here 5 kilometers away from
the starting point
that's because a travels at five
kilometers per hour and as B travels at
10 kilometers per hour it would be
somewhere here 10 kilometers away from
the starting point
now I had asked you the speed of B
relative to a so we have to find the
distance between a and B after the first
hour if this distance is 10 and this one
is 5 the distance in between will be 5
kilometers what does this tell us it
tells us that the distance between them
has increased by 5 kilometers after one
hour if they travel for one more hour
the distance between them will increase
by 5 more
kilometres it will be 10 kilometers so
we say that the speed of B relative to a
is 5 km/h the gap between them increases
by 5 kilometers every hour and how did
we get this 5 it is the difference of
the speeds of B and a it is 10 minus 5
kilometers per hour if two bodies leave
at the same time and are traveling in
the same direction then the relative
speed will be the difference of their
individual speeds to understand the
first case imagine you're seated on the
back seat of a car and you see the
stationary object when you start moving
at 10 kilometers per hour you see that
the distance between you and that object
is increasing and to understand the
second case imagine you are in the
backseat of the car and there is a car
right next to you now both start moving
at the same time you move at 10
kilometers per hour and the other car
moves at 5 kilometers per hour the
distance between your car and the other
one is increasing yes but at a slower
rate as compared to the previous case
and that is why the relative speed is
lower in the second case you are moving
away from a car at a slower rate as
compared to the rate at which you are
moving away from the stationary object
but what if the two cars are moving in
the opposite directions let's see this
is the green stationary point car a
moves towards the left at the speed of 5
kilometers per hour and car B moves
towards the right at the speed of 10
kilometers per hour and both cars leave
at the same time what will be the
relative speed here where will the Kospi
after 1 hour let this be the starting
point the speeds of 5 and 10 kilometers
per hour so car a will be somewhere here
5 kilometers away from the starting
point and D will be here 10 kilometers
away from the starting point what is the
distance between them after one hour
it's 15 kilometers the distance between
them increases at the rate of 15
kilometers per hour that's the relative
speed every hour the distance between
them will increase by 15 kilometers but
there is another case of cars moving in
opposite directions
assume that cars a and B of 40
kilometers apart Kara moves towards
right at the speed of 5 km/h and car B
moves left at the speed of 10 km/h they
are moving towards each other but it
still opposite directions
what is the relative speed here what do
you think to know the answer let's see
the positions after one hour this is the
original distance which is 40 kilometers
after one hour car a will be here five
kilometers away from this point and car
B will be here ten kilometers away from
this point what happened here an hour
ago the distance between a and B was 40
kilometers what's the distance between
them now the total is 40 minus 5 minus
10 will give us 25 kilometers it was 40
initially and is 25 after one hour the
distance between them reduced by 15
kilometers 40 minus 25 is 15 kilometers
and that is why the relative speed here
will also be 15 kilometers per hour how
do we get this 15 it is the sum of the
individual speeds 10 plus 5 kilometers
per hour so if two things start at the
same time and move in the same direction
the relative speed will be the
difference of the individual speeds and
if they start at the same time and move
in the opposite directions the relative
speed will be the sum of the individual
speeds in the next few sessions we will
look at examples based on the concept of
relative speed
you